what are the technologies
the tools that came along that made this
possible like what
what are you excited about maybe if we
just look at the buffet of things that
you've kind of mentioned is there is
this what's involved what should we be
excited about what are you excited about
i love that question because there's so
much ahead of us there's so so much
um there's uh so so basically solving
that
one locus required massive amounts of
knowledge that we have been building
across the years
through the epigenome through the
comparative genomics to find out the
causal variant and the
the controller regulatory motif through
the conserved circuitry
it required knowing this regulatory
genomic wiring
it required high c of these sort of
topologically associated domains to
basically find this long-range
interaction
it required eqtls of this sort of
genetic perturbation of these
intermediate
gene phenotypes it required all of the
arsenal of tools that i've been
describing
was put together for one locus and this
was a massive team effort
huge you know investment in time
energy money effort intellectual you
know everything
you're referring to uh i'm sorry just
one basically one yeah this one piece
this one single paper at least one
single locus i like to say that
this is a paper about one nucleotide in
the human genome about one bit of
information
c versus t in the human genome that's
one bit of information and we have 3.2
billion
nucleotides to go through so how do you
do that systematically
i am so excited about the next phase of
research
because the technologies that my group
and many other groups have developed
allows us to now do this systematically
not just one
locus at a time but thousands of loci
at a time so let me describe some of
these technologies
the first one is automation and robotics
so basically you know we talked about
how you can take
all of these molecules and see which of
these molecules are targeting each of
these genes and what do they do
so you can basically now screen through
millions of molecules
through thousands and thousands and
thousands of plates each of which has
thousands and thousands and thousands of
molecules
every single time testing you know
all of these genes and asking which of
these molecules perturb these genes
so that's technology number one
automation and robotics
technology number two is parallel
readouts
so instead of perturbing one locus
and then asking if i use crispr cast 9
on this enhancer
to basically use dcas9 to turn on or
turn off the enhancer
or if i use crystal case nine on the
snip to basically change
that one snip at a time then what
happens but we have
a hundred and twenty thousand disease
associated snips that we wanna test
we wanna we don't wanna spend 120 000
years doing it
so what do we do we've basically
developed this technology
for massively parallel reporter
assays mpra so in collaboration with
tarzan mickelson mary flanders i mean
jason dura's group has done a lot of
that so there's
there's a lot of groups that basically
have developed technologies
for testing 10 000 genetic variants at a
time
how do you do that you you know we
talked about
microarray technology the ability to
synthesize
these huge microarrays that allow you to
do all kinds of things like measure gene
expression by hybridization
by measuring the genotype of a person by
looking at hybridization with one
version with a t versus the other
version with the t
with an with a c and then sort of
figuring out that i am
a risk carrier for obesity based on
these hybridization
differential hybridization in my genome
that says oh you seem to only have this
allele or you seem to have that allele
microarrays can also be used to
systematically synthesize
small fragments of dna so you can
basically synthesize these 150
nucleotide long fragments
across 450 000 spots at a time
you can now take the result of that
synthesis
which basically works through all of
these sort of layers of adding one
occluded at a time
you can basically just type it into your
computer and order it
and you can basically order 10
000 or 100 000 of these small dna
segments at a time
and that's where awesome molecular
biology comes in you can basically take
all these segments
have a common start and end barcode or
sort of like gator like just like pieces
of a puzzle
you can make the same end piece and the
same start piece
for all of them and you can now use
plasmids which are these extra
chromosomal
small dna circular segments
that are basically inhabiting all our
all our genomes we basically have
you know plasmids floating around i mean
bacteria use plasmids
for transferring dna and that's where
they put a lot of antibiotic resistance
genes so they can easily transfer them
from but one bacterium to the other
so one bacterium involves a gene to be
resistant to
a particular antibiotic it basically
says to all its friends hey
here's that sort of dna piece
we can now co-opt these plasmids into
human cells
you can basically make a human cell
culture and add plasmids
to that human cell culture that contain
the things that you want to test you now
have this library of 450
000 elements you can insert them each
into
the common plasmid yep and then test
them
in millions of cells in parallel and the
common plasmid is all the same
before you add it exactly the rest of
the plasmid is the same
so it's it's called an episomal reporter
assay episome means not
inside the genome it's sort of outside
the chromosomes
so it's an episomal assay that allows
you to have a variable region where you
basically test
10 000 different enhancers and you have
a common region which basically has the
same reporter gene
you know some you can do some very cool
molecular biology you can basically take
the 450 000
elements that you've generated and and
you have a piece of the puzzle here a
piece of the puzzle here which is
identical so they're compatible with
that plasmid
you can chop them up in the middle to
separate a barcode
reporter from the enhancer and in the
middle put the same gene
again using the same pieces of the
bottle you now can have
a barcode readout of what is the impact
of
10 000 different versions of an enhancer
on
gene expression so we're not doing one
experiment we're doing 10 000
experiments
and those 10 000 can be 5 000
of different loci and each of them in
two versions
risk or non-risk i can now test
tens of these little hypotheses exactly
and then you can do ten thousand and we
can test ten thousand hypothesis at once
how how hard is it to generate those
ten thousand uh trivial trivial but it's
biology
no no generating the ten thousand is
trivial because you basically add
it by technology you basically have
these arrays
that that add one nucleotide at a time
at every spot
oh and yeah so it's printing in it so
you're able to you're able to control
yeah uh super costly is it 10 000 bucks
so this isn't millions 1000 bucks for 10
000 experiments sounds like the right
you know i mean so that's super that's
exciting because you don't have to do
one thing at a time
you can now use that technology these
massively parallel reporter assays to
test
10 000 locations at a time we've
made multiple modifications of that
technology one was
sharper mpra which stands for
you know basically getting
a higher resolution view by tiling
this um these elements
so you can see where along the region
of control are they acting and we made
another modification
called hydra for high you know
definition regulatory uh annotation or
something like that
which basically allows you to test seven
million of these at a time by sort of
cutting them directly from the dna
so instead of synthesizing which
basically has the limit of 450 000 that
you can synthesize at a time
we basically said hey if we want to test
all accessible regions of the genome
let's just do an experiment that cuts
accessible regions
let's take those accessible regions put
them all with the same end
joints of the puzzles and then now use
those to create
a much much larger much much larger
array of things that you can test and
then tiling all of these regions you can
then pinpoint what are the driver
nucleotides
what are the elements how are they
acting across seven million experiments
at a time so basically
this is all the same family of
technology where you're basically using
these
parallel readouts of the barcodes
and then you know to do this we used a
technology called starseek for
self-transcribing uh reporter assets a
technology developed by alex stark
my my former postdoc who's now a pi over
in vienna so we basically couple the
starsig the self-transcribing
uh reporters where the enhancer
can be part of the the gene itself so
instead of having a separate barcode
that enhancer basically acts to turn on
the gene and it's transcribed
as part of the gene so you don't have to
have the two separate parts exactly so
you can just read them
so there's a constant improvements in
this in this whole process yes uh by the
way generating all these options
are is it basically brute force uh how
much human intuition is
oh gosh of course it's human intuition
and human creativity and incorporating
all of the input data sets because again
the
the genome is enormous 3.2 billion you
don't want to test that
instead you basically use all of these
tools that i've talked about already
you generate your top favorite 10 000
hypothesis
and then you go and test all 10 000 and
then from what what comes out you can
then go
go to the next step so that's
technology number two so technology one
number one is robotics
automation where you have thousands of
wells and you constantly test them
the second technology is instead of
having wells you have these massively
parallel readouts
in sort of these pooled assays the third
technology
is coupling crispr perturbations
with these single cell rna
readouts so let me make another
parenthesis here
to describe now single cell rna
sequencing
okay so what does single cell learning
sequencing mean so
rna sequencing is what has been
traditionally used oh well traditionally
the last 20 years
ever since the advent of next generation
sequencing so basically before
rna expression profiling was based on
this microarrays
the next technology after that was based
on sequencing so you chop up your rna
and you just sequence small molecules
just like you
would sequence the genome basically
reverse transcribe these small rnas
into dna and you sequence that dna
in order to get the number of sequencing
reads
corresponding to the expression level of
every gene in the genome
you now have rna sequencing how do you
go to single cell rna sequencing
that technology also went through stages
of evolution
the first was microfluidics you
basically had
these or even even chambers you
basically had these ways of isolating
individual cells
putting them into a well for every one
of these cells
so you have 384 well plates and you not
do 384
parallel reactions to measure the
expression of 384
cells that sounds amazing and it was
amazing
but we want to do a million sales how do
you go from
you know these wells to a million sales
you can't
so what what the next technology was
after that
is instead of using a well for every
reaction you now
use a lipid droplet for every reaction
so you use micro droplets as reaction
chambers
to basically amplify rna
so here's the idea you basically have
microfluidics where you basically have
every single cell
coming down one tube in your
microfluidics and you have little
bubbles getting created in the other way
with specific primers that mark every
cell with its own barcode
you basically couple the two and you end
up with little bubbles that have
a cell and tons of markers for that cell
you now mark up all of the rna for that
one cell with the same exact barcode
and you then lyse all of the droplets
and you sequence the heck out of that
and you have for every rna molecule
a unique identifier that tells you what
cell was it on that is such good
engineering
microfluidics and uh
using some kind of primer to put it put
a put a label on the thing
i mean i don't you're making it sound
easy i assume it's it's beautiful right
challenging but it's gorgeous yeah
so there's the next generation
engineering yeah so that's the second
generation
next generation is forget the
microfluidics all together just use big
bottles
how can you possibly do that with big
bottles so here's the idea
you dissociate all of your cells or all
of your nuclei
from complex cells like brain cells that
you know are very long and sticky so you
can't do that
so you know if you have blood cells or
if you have you know neuronal nuclei or
brain nuclei
you can basically dissociate let's say a
million cells
you now want to add a unique barcode a
unique barcode in each one of a million
cells
using only big bottles i can possibly do
that sounds crazy
but here's the idea you use a hundred of
these bottles
you randomly shuffle or you're a million
cells
and you throw them into 200 bottles
randomly completely random
you add one barcode out of 100 to every
one of their cells
you then you now take them all out you
shuffle them again
and you throw them again into the same
100 bottles
but now in a different randomization
and you add a second barcode so every
cell now has
two barcodes you take them out again
you shuffle them and you throw them back
in another
third barcode is adding randomly from
the same hundred barcodes
you've now labeled every cell
probabilistically
based on the unique path that it took of
which of 100 bottles to go for the first
time
which of 100 bottles a second time and
which of 100 is a third time
100 times 100 times 100 is a million
unique barcodes
in every single one of these cells
without ever using microphones very
clever that's beautiful right computer
science perspective that's very clever
so you now have this single cell
sequencing technology you can use the
wells you can use the
bubbles or you can use the bottles and
you know sort of
you have way bubbles still sound pretty
damn because bubbles are awesome and
that's basically the main technology
that we're using okay so the evolves is
the main technology
so so there are kids now that companies
just sell
to basically carry out single cell rna
sequencing that you know you can
basically for two thousand dollars
you can basically get ten thousand cells
from one sample
and for every one of those cells you
basically
have the transcription of thousands of
genes
and you know of course the data for any
one cell is noisy
but being computer scientists we can
aggregate the data from
all of the cells together across
thousands of individuals together
to basically make very robust inferences
okay
so the third technology is basically
single cell rna sequencing that allows
you to now start asking
not just what is the brain expression
level difference of that genetic variant
but what is the expression difference of
that one genetic variant
across every single subtype of brain
cell
how is the variance changing you can't
just
you know with a brain sample you can
just ask about the mean
what is the average expression if i
instead have
3 000 cells that are neurons
i can ask not just what is the neuronal
expression
i can say for layer 5 excitatory neurons
of which i have i don't know 300 cells
what is the variance
that this genetic variant has so
suddenly
it's amazingly more powerful i can
basically start asking about this middle
layer of gene expression
at unprecedented levels and when you
look at the average it washes out
some potentially important signal
that corresponds to ultimately the
disease completely
yeah so that i can do that at the rna
level
but i can also do that at the dna level
for the epigenome
so remember how before i was telling you
about all these technologies that we're
using to probe the epigenome
one of them is dna accessibility so what
we're doing in my lab is that from the
same
dissociation of say a brain sample where
you now have all these tens of thousands
of cells floating around
you basically take half of them to do
rna profiling
and the other have to do epigenome
profiling both at the single cell level
so that allows you to now figure out
what are the millions of
dna enhancers that are accessible
in every one of tens of thousands of
cells
and computationally we can now take the
rna and the dna readout
and group them together to basically
figure out how
is every enhancer
related to every gene and remember these
sort of enhancer gene linking that we
were doing across 833 samples
833 is awesome don't get me wrong but
10 million is way more awesome so we can
now look at correlated activity
across 2.3 million enhancers and 20 000
genes
in each of millions of cells to
basically start piecing together the
regulatory circuitry
of every single type of neuron every
single type of astrocytes
oligodendrocyte
microglial cell inside the brains of
1500 individuals that we sample
across multiple different brain regions
across both dna and rna
so that's the data set that my team
generated last year alone
so in one year we basically generated 10
million cells
from human brain across a dozen
different disorders
across schizophrenia alzheimer's frontal
temporal dementia louis body dementia
als you know huntington's disease
post-traumatic stress disorder autism
like you know bipolar disorder
healthy aging etc so it's possible that
even just within that data set lie a lot
of keys
to understanding these diseases
and then be able to like directly leads
to then treatment
correct correct so basically we are now
motivating
yeah so our computational team is in
heaven right now and we're looking for
people i mean if if you have
listeners so this is a very interesting
kind of
side question how much of this is
biology how much of this is computation
so
you have the computational biology group
but how much of
i should should you be comfortable with
biology
to be able to solve some of these
problems if you
just find if you put several of the hats
you were on
fundamentally are you thinking like a
computer scientist here
you have to this is the only way
as i said we are the descendants of the
first digital computer we're trying to
understand the digital computer we
understand we're trying to understand
the circuitry the logic
of this digital you know core computer
and all of these analog layers
surrounding it
so you you know the case that i've been
making is that you cannot think one gene
at a time
the traditional biology is dead there's
no way you cannot solve disease with
traditional biology
you need it as a component once you've
figured out rx3 and rx5
you now can then say hey have you guys
worked on those genes with your single
gene approach
we'd love to know everything you know
and if you haven't we now know how
important these genes are
let's now launch a single gene program
to dissect them and understand them
but you cannot use that as a way to
dissect disease you have to think
genomically
you have to think from the global
perspective and you have to build these
circuits
systematically so we need numbers of
computer scientists who are
interested and willing to dive into this
data
you know fully fully in and sort of
extract meaning we need computer science
people who can understand sort of
machine learning and
inference and sort of you know decouple
these matrices
come up with super smart ways of sort of
dissecting them
but we also need by computer scientists
who understand biology
who are able to design the next
generation of experiments
because many of these experiments no one
in their right mind would design them
without thinking of the analytical
approach that you would use to
deconvolve the data afterwards
right because it's massive amounts of
ridiculously noisy data
and if you don't have the computational
pipeline
in your head before you even design the
experiment you would never design the
experiment that way
that's brilliant so you in designing the
experiment you have to see the entirety
of the computational pipeline
that drives the design that that even
drives the necessity for that design
basically
you know if you didn't have a computer
scientist way of thinking
you would never design these hugely
combinatorial
massively parallel experiments
so that's why you need interdisciplinary
teams you need teams
and and i want to i want to sort of
clarify that what do we mean by
computational biology group
the focus is not on computational the
focus is on the biology
so we are a biology group what type of
biology
computational biology is the type of
that uses the whole genome that's the
type of biology that designs
experiments genomic experiments that can
only be interpreted in the context of
the whole genome
right so it's it's philosophically
looking at biology as a computer
correct correct so which is a
in the context of the history of biology
is a big transformation
yeah yeah you can think of the name as
what do we do
only computation that's not true but how
do we study it
only computationally that is true so all
of these single cell sequencing
can now be coupled with the technologies
that we talked about earlier for
perturbation
so here's a crazy thing instead of using
these wells
and these robotic systems for doing one
drug
at a time or for perturbing one gene at
a time
in thousands of wells you can now do
this
using a pool of cells and single cell or
any sequencing
how you basically can take these
perturbations using crispr
and instead of using a single guide rna
you can use a library of guide rnas
generated exactly the same way using
this array technology
so you synthesize a thousand different
guide rnas
you now take each of these guide rnas
and you insert them in a pool of cells
where every cell gets one perturbation
and you use crispr editing
or crispr uh so with either crispr cas9
to edit the genome
with these thousand perturbations or the
or with the activation
or with the repression and you now can
have a single cell readout
where every single cell has received one
of these modifications and you can now
in massively parallel ways
couple the perturbation and
the readout in a single experiment how
are you tracking which perturbations
yourself received so there's there's
ways of doing that
but basically one way is to make that
perturbation an expressible
vector so that part of your rna reading
is actually
that perturbation itself so you can
basically put it in a
expressible part so you can self-drive
it
so the the point that i want to get
across is that the sky is the limit
you basically have these tools these
building blocks of molecular biology
you have these massive data sets of
computational biology
you have this huge ability to sort of
use
machine learning and statistical methods
and you know linear algebra to sort of
reduce the dimensionality of all these
massive data sets
and then you end up with a series of
actionable targets that you can then
couple with pharma and just go after
systematically
so the ability to sort of bring genetics
to the epigenomics to the
transcriptomics to the cellular readouts
using these sort of high throughput
perturbation technology that i'm talking
about
and ultimately to the organismal through
the
electronic health record and do
phenotypes and ultimately the disease
battery of assays at the cognitive level
at the physiological level
and you know every other level
this there is no better or more exciting
field in my view
to be a computer scientist then or to be
a scientist in period
basically this confluence of
technologies of computation
of data of insight and of tools for
manipulation
is unprecedented in human history and i
think this is what's shaping
the next century to really be a
transformative century for our species
and for our planet
you